i got a ton of questions for you and um
so uh they're all over the spectrum but
i want to start with you have produced a
ton of movies and television shows if
someone had never seen anything you have
made
what do you want them starting with
uh get out
that was an immediate
that was an immediate because at best it
it it it's the ultimate of what i'm
trying to do it's low budget
it's uh it's a it's a director who at
the time
nobody believed in
um
it's scary
it's entertaining it's well acted and it
has something to say you know i mean
it's it's like the perfect blumhouse
movie in in in in
in every way really
in the past 10 years
what it has been the toughest project
for you to get off the ground
uh
i mean there are there are a handful of
them there's a there's a there's a movie
that looks like it's actually you know
getting closer but stoner i've had for
over 10 years
uh there's an uh which is a a a a
a novel a great american novel
um
there's a there's a movie based on an
article called spec in the sea about
these two fishermen this great this
great story of these two fishermen in
montauk um that i'm still trying to get
off the ground those are the two those
are the two front runners of the hardest
ever to to get done
uh jumping into welcome to the blum
house um
amazon doesn't really release numbers
and i'm just curious last year with the
films that you released um how did they
do like no one ever actually says it
well that's a great question because i'm
i'm uh i i i think it's very important
it's very important to me as a filmmaker
to know how our movies performed so they
actually were very transparent with us
about the performance of the movies they
don't say it publicly but at least they
say it to the filmmakers
and they were very transparent with us
and the movies did very well they were
they were very happy with them some did
better than others what they were most
happy with
is that they got um
new subscribers or subscribers who had
um
you know
discontinued and then they they opened
up their subscription again which was
great which means we we tapped into a
different audience than
all the other all the other all the
other people working on
on uh
all the other shows that amazon was
doing and um
and uh
and in terms of the you know proof is in
the pudding always so i think if the if
this next four movies performs
as well as the last four then we're
gonna do this uh we're gonna continue to
do this and i hope i hope we'll continue
for quite a long time i'm quite
confident that we will
what did you learn making the films last
year that you applied to these films
you know i learned that um i didn't i
last we we set out to do eight movies by
eight directors from underrepresented
groups of people and what we wanted what
i wanted to do this year more than we
did the first time around was have that
not only choose the director but have
the actual movies
relate to that so have the movies be
about marginalized groups
and i think the movies the four movies
work more cohesively as a whole and that
all
each of these movies is very clearly
about a marginalized group of people on
screen um so so underrepresented
directors telling stories um
that uh from a different point of view
from a point of view that people who
look like you and i haven't haven't felt
before
how does it work with amazon in terms of
you obviously have an amazing track
record after the first four films are
they are they like a little hands-off
how much are they collaborating and
which films are actually going to get
made
they leave that to us but i don't i
wouldn't you know i'd be very reluctant
to make a movie if they laid down on the
tracks and said don't please don't do
this i wouldn't do it but technically
they don't have the right to do that i
get to choose the movies um um and so
far it's we've agreed we've never had a
case where i wanted to make something
they haven't wanted to make
um one of the things that i really uh
admire and respect about these uh films
that you're making is you're you're
bringing in a lot of new voices and a
a lot of them are first-time feature
filmmakers even though they've made
shorts or whatever else when do you know
when you're talking to someone they can
do it they they can make a feature and
this is going to be good you don't know
until after they've done the movie to
tell you the truth but
but uh you know you try and meet with
them a few times and uh we have
executives at the company who do that
and um
and you've got to go go with your gut
but you never really know if someone
could make a movie until the movie's
done you never know
with the four films that are coming out
uh in a few days and in a week um if
someone has the time to watch one movie
on a friday night which is the one you'd
like them to start with of the four i
can't pick a favorite i can't pick a
favorite but uh but yeah it's not like
anyone's gonna watch this come on i'm
joking about it yeah right but uh but uh
but but watch the first one that's on if
you like that then watch the next three
okay um when i mentioned on twitter that
i was going to be talking to you and
when i mentioned to my staff something
that came up a number of times was um
five nights at freddy's everyone kept on
being like what's going on with that so
i'm asking you what's going what's going
on with that it's you know it's really
tough to crack um
we've written
multiple scripts
um and uh
and we've got we're threading a needle
which is which is doing justice to five
nights at freddy's and
making scott happy you know the only way
that we would go about it is is uh
giving scott um you know i don't want to
do something that scott doesn't like
um and uh or in fact but let me say that
a different way i don't have the right
to do anything scott doesn't like scott
has basically scott has kind of like the
equivalent of final cut
um
and uh and it's taken longer than i
hoped to find uh to get the right to get
the right story but um but we have we're
a long ways from giving up and i'm
confident eventually i will figure it
out
is chris columbus still attached
chris columbus is no longer attached
do you have a filmmaker on it or is it
where can you share we cannot we can
that is that is classified information
i'll leave it alone um what's going on
with uh wolfman
wolfman we are also working on the
script working on the script got to get
the script right in that case it's uh
it's ryan gosling not scott cawthorn but
uh but working on trying to get a script
that um that he feels good about and
comfortable about and excited about
um you are going into business with john
logan who i'm a big fan of and he's
going to make his future directorial
debut with you um
already he started shooting
so i was going to ask you what was it
about that project that said i want to
make this
um you know it felt like it felt like uh
you know reference your first question
at the beginning it definitely felt like
a blumhouse movie um it's a scary great
fun entertaining movie he has a you know
if anyone can write it's john logan but
it's also about something so i was very
drawn to that we had made a documentary
about conversion therapy called pray
away so it's it's a topic um
near to my heart only in that i just
find it it's just one of those things
like i find it extraordinary that that
in the united states that exists i just
i just i just find it unbelievable um
and and and
and i think it's like a horrible it
should be illegal you know it's it's
it's
it should not be allowed and the the
misery that these
you know these poor these kids suffer
going through it uh i just find it very
sad and so i wanna shine a light on it
any way i can and uh the documentary did
but not not very many people saw it so
i'm hoping a movie a lot more people
will see but just just to be clear i
didn't pitch the idea to john logan he
came up with it he wrote that script
entirely on his own on spec and when i
read it i said oh my god i love this we
want to do it but it but he was his eye
it was entirely his idea
yeah i'm i'm saying thank you for uh
making the movie because i also agree
with everything you said um
i'm also a huge brian fuller fan and i
know you're gonna be hopefully what's
the story with uh uh christine and him
uh we actually uh recently got a script
which was uh which was terrific and uh
we're gonna try to make it into a movie
that's my plan
got it do you think it's going to be
filming
do you think it could be filming next
year
no never say never i'm an optimist
okay another film you've made that i
love is upgrade
love that movie um
upgrade was a great movie oh my god it's
so good and i know you guys have talked
about making a tv series based on the
material um
sure upgrade should have been a wide
release so i was pissed about that uh i
am by the way is [ __ ] great so anyone
who's watching this who has not seen it
needs to see it it's the upgrade show c
upgrade um working on the scripts this
first round didn't come out um
you know i i didn't get the response i
wanted to get i don't want to be in
development i want an order so i'm going
to we're working on the scripts again so
that we can get an order and i don't
want to develop it
halloween kills is getting a
day-and-date release on peacock yes in
theaters can you sort of talk about how
that came about and
um and i guess your feelings on it
because a lot of us were surprised but i
also think peacock needs
like movies like that to get people to
sign up
well that's true that's not why it was
my idea to do it they didn't approach me
i approached them i i i um
like everyone else i'm a big believer in
the theatrical experience i think
eventually i think there should be
windows i think universal strategy of
the three-week window is a great
strategy but i just i just i i had a a
bad distribution experience with freaky
like it just that movie is a great movie
and it didn't get seen because
the distribution of it got got all
twisted up my fault
and i didn't want to go through that
experience again i didn't want to have a
movie that i'm really proud of that i
think is great and have there be an
excuse why people didn't see it so i'm
the one who um
pitched universal and then i pitched
jamie and david and it was my idea and
i'm and i'm i stand behind it i'm glad
that we're doing it i don't want to do
it for the third movie um
um
i i i want to go back to traditional
windows but i don't you know this you
know covid is is incredibly
unpredictable and i didn't want to risk
it again and i and i felt like we did i
did that with freaky in it and it
left me with a bad taste in my mouth so
i don't want i don't want to want to
repeat that experience
what is actually the status of the of
the universal monster movies that you're
working on besides wolfman do you have
other what other films are you sort of
developing
we do we have uh we have two or three
we're developing they're not they're not
yet announced so i can't talk about them
but uh but the status with universal
monsters is no different than it's ever
been universal is in charge of the
universal monsters but um but we've come
up with a few ideas that they've liked
for a few of their other ones and and
hopefully we'll turn those into movies
i'm out of time but i just have to ask
you real quick uh are you making a happy
death day three
i have i have i have a plan i have i'm
not put it this way i'm not saying
goodbye to happy death day i'll say it
like that
got it i'm gonna leave it there and just
say i had other questions but i'm out of
time um listen uh
always great to talk with you and um
congratulations on breaking a hundred
thousand twitter followers thank you
thank you thank you please help me get
more i i already i mean i think it was
my tweet that got you over the edge i
appreciate that buddy i appreciate that
was a big moment for me